one of the things you pointed out too
was that what you most need to know will
be found where you least want to look
and that's because you haven't already
looked there and so it's a little
different for everyone right because
you're a particular place you don't want
to look isn't going to be the same as
your place but you're going to have a
place you don't want to look and what
you haven't discovered that's where it
is
and so that's all partly going to be
discovered by you looking at what you're
capable of what you're truly capable of
it
you know people especially on the
compassionate and saying well no I could
never be like brutal like that and that
could be true but you can kill people
with compassion no problem it happened
that's a Freudian eatables situation so
think about working in a nursing home so
there's actually a rule of thumb which I
also use to guide my interactions with
children and also with my clients and I
would say with people in general do not
do anything for anyone that they can do
themselves all you do is steal you just
steal it from them so imagine you're
working with really elderly people you
know they have elf fibers it's like
really easy to do things for them
because well it isn't because it's a
really hard job but it might be easier
to do something for them than to let
them struggle through it but you just
speed their device right by taking away
their last vestiges of their
independence and you do the same thing
with kids it's like struggle through it
man did you ever see my left foot that's
a great movie it's about this author
whose name escapes me at the moment
brilliant it's brilliant movie and the
person who played the part Daniel
day-lewis I think he won a Academy Award
for it but it's about this author in
Ireland who was I think he had cerebral
palsy and all he could really do was use
his left foot that was it the rest of
him was pretty spastic and not in not
controllable but he was there he was
very intelligent he was with it and his
dad would not help him he had to drag
himself up the damn stairs with his left
foot he just would not help him and what
happened was he learned how to live you
know he actually he couldn't function
and the movie does the book which is
called my left foot in the movie does a
lovely job of laying that out but you
have to be one hard hard
son of a bitch to let your son crawl up
the stairs with his left foot over and
over you think about that but what's the
alternative you know if he would have
been and of course he lays this out in
the book if he would have been catered
to he would have ended up just like
you'd expect someone who was always
catered to so it's a very nice lesson in
the triumph of fostering independence
over the over too casual compassion
that's what I would say